charest bon jour en jour du roi on a
entendu votre avocat judy parler de
l'enquète ma chérie oui on en parlera de
ça je vous posais des questions bien sûr
mais je veux savoir ce que je parle aux
candidats jean charest ou aux citoyens
george à voilà vous parler aux citoyens
juin parce que après avoir réfléchi
longuement après avoir été beaucoup
sollicités pour la chefferie du parti
conservateur est sollicité parce que les
enjeux actuels au canada c'est des
enjeux sur lesquels beaucoup de gens
pensent que je peux offrir du leadership
la question de l'unité du pays qui est
beaucoup défini mais ma vie question
d'économie finances publiques
l'environnement des ressources
naturelles les changements climatiques
qui mène les affaires internationales
j'ai beaucoup réfléchi j'ai consulté et
et finalement je prends la décision de
ne pas être candidat pour les raisons
suivantes d'abord parce que les règles
de la course au leadership sont restés
dans le fond des règles en pot et écrite
pour un candidat qui de l'extérieur des
échéanciers sont très serrés ça donne
pas beaucoup de temps pour recruter des
nouveaux membres et de mettre sur pied
une organisation nationale la deuxième
raison c'est que le parti beaucoup
changé depuis 1998 quand j'ai quitté il
ya des sujets sur lesquels manger après
nombre de principes qui vont pas changer
alors je dis pas que ça changera jamais
dans le parti une course au leadership
c'est fait pour ça mais c'est pas le
parti vous avez qui n'ont milieu des
années 80 un état des lieux que j'ai
fait et finalement j'ai une vie
familiale mais j'ai une vie
professionnelle vie familiale heureuse
vie professionnelle qui est également
très active
alors quand on fait le bilan de tous
âges en arrive à la conclusion que je
vais pas être candidat et mais mon
souhait cependant c'est que on puisse
avoir une alternative national au parti
libéral du canada c'est très important
pour le pays
il ya beaucoup de gens qui pensent comme
moi qui sont pas du tout partisan
libéral-conservateur npd puisque disent
qu'ils savent que pour l'avenir du
canada
il faut absolument avoir des partis
politiques sont capacité d'enchaîner
revenons à vous quand même ouais à quel
moment vous avez pris c'est définitif
vous ne serez pas candidat je ne serai
pas candidat c'est définitif il remporte
une annonce à vous directement
aujourd'hui en primeur jusqu'à quel
point ça vous a vraiment vraiment tendu
on a parlé des gens pendant les vacances
de noël quand sébastien beauvais est
lancé le secoue
on a vérifié si c'était vrai vous avez
confirmé jusqu'où vous vouliez vraiment
mon coeur beaucoup balancé
alors pendant toute la période des fêtes
monsieur roy j'ai fait des téléphones je
parle à des gens j'ai reçu une avalanche
de courriels
ça a été j'ai repris contact des gens
qui ont repris contact avec moi avec qui
j'avais travaillé 30 ans politique qui
m'encourageait y aller alors j'ai
beaucoup beaucoup consulté
j'ai parlé aux gens qui sont très actifs
et militer dans le parti actuellement et
donc mon coeur beaucoup balancé ses pas
ne dit si jamais les décisions qu'ils
sont noirs ou blancs parce qu'il ya
tellement de
de conséquences mais je reviens à ce que
je vous disais y un instant les règles
de la course au leadership de parti a
changé moi ya des sujets sur lesquels
est évidemment jeu des princes et
l'environnement l'environnement des
questions aussi des questions sociales
dos et aborde des questions sociales sur
lesquelles j'ai j'ai pris des positions
des contrôle des armes à feu par exemple
où nous sous mon gouvernement on a
rapatrié le registre des armes à feu ça
c'est des sujets sur lesquels j'ai pris
des positions qui sont quand même très
importante je vous le disais d'entrée de
jeu monsieur charest je lui dis votre
avocat de vendredi stature et une
entrevue et demandant votre nom d'une
certaine façon
l'arrêt de l'anc est mature vous n'êtes
jamais expliquée sur ma chérie elle big
man est ce qu'aujourd'hui vous prenez
une part de responsabilité dans cette
dérive du financement du parti libéral
du québec
d'abord monsieur roy joe diffie très
aujourd'hui serein et heureux d'avoir
l'occasion de parler lorsque depuis que
j'ai quitté la politique sur ce sujet là
vous avez remarqué j'ai pas fai
d'intervention j'ai pas fai
d'intervention pendant la période de la
commission charbonneau parce que mon
gouvernement l'avait mis sur pied et
pendant laquelle être aussi parce qu'ils
m'ont étonné qu'il ya une enquête mais
en fait parce qu'on veut pas avoir l'air
d'intervenir mais là ça fait six ans que
ça dure randonnée un élément de bon sens
ce que mon avocat a dit à votre collègue
c'est en réponse à une question qui lui
est posée et qui relèvent du bon sens
c'est qu'à un moment donné il faut que
ça finisse d'ailleurs le premier
ministre legault pas plus tard
qu'aujourd'hui au fait un commentaire
qui est à peu près le même temps j'ai
hâte que ça finisse speak la conclusion
ça c'est une affaire de bon sens le
surpoids mais alors mais à un moment
donné il se la joue donc pu d'ailleurs
vous avez envoyé votre avocat c'est là
je dis peut-être qu'ils ne se rendront
jamais devant les tribunaux moi je vous
ramène sur la joute politique et sur la
part de responsabilité qu'un chef
à quand il voit son parti que vous
l'avez constaté le fameux financement
sectoriel ou votre ami pierre bibeau
parcelles chapeau auprès des firmes de
génie aux frais des firmes d'avocats aux
frais des firmes de construction
ces fermes le s'attendait à avoir des
contrats faisait-il chef du parti
quelle est votre part de responsabilité
d'abord j'assume mes responsabilités
et pas question de se défiler et je suis
imputables de la période où j'étais chef
du parti libéral du québec est premier
ministre
cela étant dit c'est quoi les faits
c'est quoi les faits dans la période où
j'étais chef du parti libéral du québec
en passant il ya des gens d'urbaine qui
veut que nous on faisait plus de
financement que jamais auparavant alors
que c'est faux
il y avait plus de financements l'époque
de monsieur bourassa qui en avait à
l'époque où j'étais chef du parti
libéral du québec pourtant monsieur roux
a sonné c'est comme une légende urbaine
bourassa mais est-ce que ce dont je veux
vous dire c'est qu'il est plein de
légendes urbaines dessus il ya eu a eu
le rapport moisan le rapport moisan a
établi pour la première fois qu'ils
avaient eu du final
ce manque on appelait par prête-noms et
à ce moment là dans le rapport moisan
c'est pas le parti libéral du québec est
visé c'est le parti québécois le juge -
à vos mains dire dans son rapport que le
parti libéral du québec ne savait pas or
on a fait quoi monsieur roy lorsque cet
événement la can le rapport a été déposé
on a fait en sorte que tous ceux qui se
disent tu es devait dire à ceux qui
donnaient que fallait que ça vienne de
leur poche époque
d'ailleurs ça a été changée et après ça
on a changé les lois 2010 ok alors on a
agi moi j'ai agi mais avant d'agir vous
étiez vous au courant des pratiques de
votre ami monsieur bibeau d'avoir un
code monsieur bibeau est un ami sa piste
encore draghi oui c'est toujours un ami
c'est bien que je n'aie jamais permettez
moi de vous dire que je n'ai jamais
douté de la netteté de monsieur bible
encore aujourd'hui encore aujourd'hui
jamais un seul instant où les chars et
oui mais le public en lui depuis jeudi
les mains des policiers
ce daigle coordinateur du plq dans votre
partie d'hier on allait ramasser 4
millions dans le secteur yale rosaire
sauriol la firme dessau que des sceaux
participer au financement pour le
réseautage avoir accès aux décideurs
on voulait pas se nuire monsieur lafleur
bpr qu'il avait le sentiment de devoir
donner au plq
si votre ami qui sera l'une est monsieur
bibeau qui se promenaient au près ces
gens là étaient faits sur youtube voir
des contrats ce serait tellement études
à achat vous dites ça n'a pas existé où
vous dites si ça existe et je ne le
savais pas je ne crois pas j'en crois
pas un mot poinçonnet vendredi d'abord
vous venez de le dire vous quelqu'un dit
j'avais le sentiment que je devais
donner
est ce que avoir le centre alors que ce
qui a été rendu public la semaine
dernière tout ça avait été rendu public
devant la commission charbonneau
tous avaient déjà été dit n'est ce pas
la commission charbonneau ça a duré 4 1
ça a coûté 40 millions de dollars
le co-commissaire renaud lachance écrit
dans leur rapport qu'après avoir écouté
tous les témoins que tous les témoins
monsieur roy était une
m pour dire qu'ils n'avaient pas de lien
entre le financement et l'attribution de
contrats
oui vous avez raison sur la chanson
voilà madame charbonneau dit autre chose
mais là vous parlez du lien entre je
vous donne je vais recevoir regrettera
mais la violation de la loi électorale
donc la violation pénale de dire telle
firme va donner cinquante mille qu'on va
demander aux employés de faire des
chèques convoler rembourser vous saviez
que ça existait on ne savait pas que ça
existait le rapport cette partie se voit
le rapport moisan le juge - dit très
clairement que le parti libéral du
québec dans le coq qui l'a examiné ne le
savais pas il écrit noir sur blanc dans
son rapport après ça monsieur roy nous
avons nous modifier nos pratiques pour
informer les gens qui nous donnaient de
l'argent que il fallait qu'ils le
fassent en prenant la leur patrimoine et
après somme le suroît nous avons même
changer les lois pour que ça devienne
une interdiction noir sur blanc très
bien donc vous excluez aujourd'hui après
toutes ces années que monsieur bibeau a
pu faire des choses illégales ou en
violation de la loi électorale
moi je connais exclusion à votre esprit
j'exclus ça je connais monsieur bibeau
c'est un homme en ait jamais eu un
instant j'ai jamais eu un seul doute sur
son son honnêteté
mais attention de vous me rapportez des
choses qui viennent de l'upac juste
besoin de vous rappeler aujourd'hui que
l'upac est sous enquête que l'upac dans
la sphère de guy ouellette a écrit des
affidavits aussi et sur lequel ils ont
été totalement discrédités que le
directeur général de l'upac a
démissionné le jour de l'élection que le
directeur général la sûreté du québec
que je connais que qui j'ai beaucoup de
respect suspendu que aujourd'hui le
numéro 2 de l'upac a également
démissionné alors les allégations d'affi
david vous allez poublan mais si je
prends ça avec un grain de sel
ce n'est pas vous êtes d'accord avec moi
pour dire que ce n'est pas des faits
avérés que c'est pas des faits qui sont
prouvés aux attaquants avec moi briche
d'accord avec vous dans ce char et mais
il ya beaucoup
beaucoup beaucoup de gens dans le milieu
des affaires qui racontent la même
histoire
et là je vous parle pas de prouver
devant un tribunal mais qui racontent la
même histoire la même chaîne qui devait
donner sinon il sentait exclu qu'ils
avaient peur de perdre des contrats plus
eu la prudence ne devrait pas vous faire
dire peut-être c'est arrivé si c'est
arrivé je le condamne et je m'en dit
ceci parce que vous semblez succès pour
arriver à quitter en attendez attendez
ce que je vous dis c'est que si c'est
arrivé
évidemment que je m'en dit ceci mais ce
que je vous dis en même temps c'est que
j'ai la conviction que monsieur bebo en
particulier n'a pas fait ce qu'on lui
reproche tout ce que certains lui
reprochent et qu' aucune preuve à cet
effet qu'il ya des gens qui peuvent bien
dire j'ai comme vous l'avez dit
vous-même décrit comment il y avait le
sentiment d'avoir le sentiment s'est pas
exactement la même chose que dire noir
sur blanc il m'a demandé que c'est pas
du tout la main jouée mais ces choses
vous savez comment ça se fait on dit pas
à quelqu un chef d'entreprise
si tu donnes pas tel contrat ex y z te
le donnerai pas yatuu un autre chose sur
laquelle on peut s'attendre à aucun
instant ce sont les contributions sont
reliés aux contrôles sur moi c'est
renaud lachance l'écrit noir sur blanc
après avoir écouté tous les témoins
pendant quatre ans la commission de la
question sur monsieur bibeau comment se
fait il qu'il se promenait selon georges
dit qu ancien président de rsw avec une
carte d'affaires avec le logo du
gouvernement du québec et surtout pas un
seul instant vous n'y croyez pas non pas
du tout pas un seul instant et donc vous
restez je crois que non pas simplement
par loyauté mais vous restez non non non
c'est pas une question de loyauté vous
me demandez si monsieur byblos prenait
qu'une carte d'affaires du gouvernement
du québec non au contraire je crois pas
son kit ou pas une seule seconde
et quand les policiers allègue dans leur
document que vous vous mais liées plus
que d'autres chefs de financement vous
avez vous avez pas rencontré les
policiers directement dedans parce qu'on
a affaire de rencontrer les policiers de
collaborer avec les policiers de l'upac
mais ils ont peu répondu à cet appel
l'homme sur web saas et les mêmes
policiers qui ont pas rencontré nathalie
normandeau qui est une autre affaire de
l'upac qui est en train de s'écraser
alors pardonnez moi si j'ai un petit peu
de scepticisme sur les affidavit de
l'upac
quant à nathalie normandeau se fait
accuser demandent un procès puis que
personne ne semble capable de lui donner
le procès qu'elle a déclaré que dans le
cas de guy ouellette la faire c'est
complètement écrasé dans le code l'upac
sur la fois david habib qui ont été
discrédités monsieur un moment donné à
un moment donné faisons aussi la part
des choses vous demandez quoi du pack
moi j'ai rien demandé à du pack a pas
que de demander que ils agissent de
manière responsable et que le gros bon
sens fait en sorte qu'un jour ils tirent
des conclusions et je pose seul à le
demander le premier ministre du québec
françois legault
aujourd'hui même demande la même chose
mais sur voie mais je pêche parce qu'ils
avaient attaqué mêmes conclusions que
vous me rapport écouter aussi vous
pensez que je sais pas mais c'est quoi
la conséquence que ça a joué
monsieur charest ce que ça a joué dans
votre décision vous nous avez un dossier
quatre minutes de ne pas vous présente
ses impôts à jouer puis je vais vous
dire pourquoi ne pas jouer d'une amp
parce que j'ai ça dans le décor depuis
six ans monsieur roy c'est c'est dans le
domaine public tout ça vous allez vous
le savez c'est un coulage toute ma vie
privée a été a été répandu dans le
domaine public
parce que vu un coulage de l'upac il
souffre sont sous enquête pour ça c'est
connu depuis très longtemps alors je me
serais jamais
j'aurais jamais évoqué la possibilité
d'être candidat si j'avais senti pour un
seul instant qu'une affaire comme ça
était et est sujet aux poursuites ou que
ça allait nuire
est-ce que vous sentiez que monsieur
harper par exemple peut être utilisé ce
genre de choses non la question éthique
moi j'ai parlé à mes yeux un peu avant
noël on a eu une très bonne conversation
ça a été très courtois
monsieur à peu m'a dit qu'il n'y avait
pas piller personnes pendant la course
au leadership que c'était pas c'était
pas son intention j'ai pas demandé à
monsieur rare un peu de métier j'ai eu
une relation qui est très bonne avec pas
très bonne maison respectueuse avec lui
on a eu des désaccords sur le plan
politique lui des accords très
importants entre autres les questions
d'environnement
mais oui mais pour le reste non ok donc
aucun regret face à vos agissements
s'ils ont raison parce que toujours aux
cats en deçà de même vous savez sûrement
fait toujours jouer les films a essayé
de refaire la vie à l'envers peut dire
mais moi la question que je me pose est
la suivante est-ce que j'ai agi lorsque
j'ai eu des informations sur les
pratiques de financement qui étaient des
pratiques qui n'étaient pas conformes
aux lois et la réponse est oui répond si
oui on a changé les instructions qu'on
donnait mais sur roue à chaque fois nous
qu'on parlait de financement caucus du
parti libéral du québec et dans des
instances du parti
à chaque fois j'insistais pour rappeler
aux gens qu'il fallait respecter les
règles et je le faisais religieuses même
sur donc vous n'avez pas besoin
pourquoi on irait prendre le risque de
contourner d'abord parce que c'est pas
acceptable mais on avait tout ce qu'il
fallait pour faire des financements
appelé réussi
l'ironie encore aujourd'hui là dessus le
financement qu'on faisait c'était moins
que ce que faisait dé nos prédécesseurs
puis pourtant aujourd'hui vous
puis tous vos collègues continuer à dire
que c'est une machine à imprimer de
l'argent alors que c'est faux
sarah massier quand même j'ai ouï
j'hésitais votre se déglingue 4 millions
par année de sectoriel c'est quand même
pas mal d'argent oui on faisait mais
tout cela était convenu le web statique
hellip des autres partis politiques en
faisait de même 600 aussi les règles
quelle est la suite pour vous dans cette
histoire-là cette grande histoire du
financement politique allait la suite
vous attendez donc une décision de
l'upac
puis vous avez sauvé sa grande nulle
part dont ben vous racontez lui tacle à
interroger ils ont dit publiquement
environ 300 personnes sont allés
rencontrer pour donner l'idée on a
besoin de parties de pêche ils sont
allés rencontrer les organisateurs de
mon assemblée de mise en candidature à
sherbrooke en 1984 quand je veux 25
l'upac a interrogé des témoins et ont
demandé un témoin particulier si mon
épouse michelle est un gentil avec le
personnel
ça a été ça d alors qu'est ce que c'est
monsieur roy quand soudainement on part
sur une enquête on interroge 300
personnes sur la vie de quelqu'un si
c'est parce qu'on appelle une partie de
pêche
alors c'est ça a été chose que du perco
fils et est ce que quelqu'un peut nous
blanc mais aujourd'hui c'est le premier
ministre du québec puis tout le monde
puis vous aussi je présume disque après
six ans s'il n'y avait pas d'accusation
a porté en nettement mais qu'est ce qui
empêchait l'upac de porter des
accusations
depuis six ans à rien y'a rien
absolument rien que les empêcher de
porter des accusations revient à la
preuve devant un tribunal devant le cour
et la zone plus politique la zone morale
la zone éthiques
mais là-dessus ben c'est ça qui
m'intéresse davantage moi je propose ici
je peux avocat vous êtes je n'ai rien à
me reprocher au niveau éthique dans
toutes ces années là et je n'ai pas
faire en sorte que le il ya eu un bris
de confiance entre la population et les
élites politiques sur les questions de
finances maison du charbonneau et
c'était comme si là dessus vous prenez
aucun blanc bref en conclusion j'ai agi
de manière responsable
si c'était à refaire on ferait
probablement des règles qui seraient
plus contraignantes encore mais c'est
facile pour moi de dire aujourd'hui
monsieur roy serait facile pour boîtes
zerah jeu dans mon âme et conscience à
chaque fois qu'on est et nous on est
informé qu'il y avait des choses qui se
faisaient qui est en dehors des lois
nous avons agi même que le parti libéral
du québec a pas attendu d'être
interpellé lorsqu'on à rembourser de
l'argent
parce que ça avait été donnée par prêts
dont le parti libéral du québec a pris
l'initiative peuvent faire des
remboursements alors agi de manière
responsable
j'aurais merci pour cette entrevue il y
aura d'autres occasions j'imagine pour
vous de parler de tout seul et on va
attendre
effectivement les conclusions de cette
opération la merci à la première cible
sur one au revoir